die schwerkraft macht man atomkraftwerk
kurz sich schwer an ist aber gar nicht
schwer
ihr habt genug strom für 30 folgen ich
sage mal sagt also atomkraftwerke lieber
nicht machen wenn ich sage man falls wir
irgendwo dieses experience beenden
möchte gern atomkraftwerk machen weil
dann kann es passieren wenn die
kernschmelze eintritt dass alles was du
hier überhaupt sehen kannst ein riesiger
krater weißt du das hier habe ich meine
jemand lesen macht das atomkraftwerk war
gesetzt schlecht dafür das hat alles
über alles zerstörte und gesagt weil er
selbst so schlechter für das ja net
hätte ein thema welches welche filme ich
auch gerne zum beispiel action fahren
ich habe letztens zum beispiel noch den
film stirb langsam geguckt und den fans
sehr geil ich finde den film inception
sehr geil social network find ich geil
ich hätte auch solche filme wie wall
street 2 zum beispiel ganz einfach nur
um wirtschaft und unberührt börse geht
aber völlig warum dargestellt er
wirklich so ich muss noch ein paar
sachen lagern 1 verlor
also ich hab da ich die komplette
bandbreite aber es muss irgendwie was
mit mit einer richtig guten story um mit
guten schauspielern sein und du simon
ich mag zum beispiel ist gerne filme
wohl ich mag zum beispiel keine
romantischen unsere schleuse das mag ich
ihn noch nicht
wenn er schon den frauen kann man ist
dann verspricht der film schon nicht gut
ich finde es einfach nur langweilig wird
es darum möglichst weiß nicht würde
solange ich bin am wenigsten ich bin
generell menschen film und dinge zum
letzten mal freundin zum beispiel die
komplette herr der ringe trilogie gut
von der hobbit angefangen weil wir im
kopf haben und dann kam noch mal
dreiteiligen serie 1 2 und 3
die filme dauernder übels langweilig war
stunden und wir haben da wirklich paar
wochen brauchen bis sie durch cook haben
wir hinter abend stück davon abhaben
aber so spielt ist aber halb einfinden
damit hast du den film die empfehlung
aber in zwei teile gesplittet
woche wir haben sechs filme daraus
gemacht weil ihn zwei stunden bis bittet
also es war ein prophet 4 stunden haben
immer 24 stunden raus gemacht also bei
vier stück jedes weiß ich aber ich muss
nicht lang sein
früher hat es viele dinge übrig auch
jetzt mag ich es richtig gerne also ich
freue mich auf den hobbit teil 2 ich
brauche irgendwie was voraus ich mir
dass ich mir so viel machen kann oder so
was haben wir denn da eigentlich gar
nicht reisen zum beispiel ja aber wir
haben keine reise mehr hatte ich möchte
meine saphir schaufel haben ja und wir
haben noch sieben saphir
da kriegst du aber nicht wie schnell ist
jetzt ja die ist so schnell wie einreise
schaufel doch genossen da sein ich genau
das gleiche glaube ich wollte es jetzt
auch mal genau machen sechs freunde
machen genau du kannst übrigens ich
mache den weg jetzt erst mal gerade du
kannst du nachher noch zu recken
reinbringen wenn du willst dass er so
ein bisschen ab gegangen haben soll
meinte stoya kannst du dann immer noch
bernd machen wie auch mal zweiter
das vergessen schon wieder ich kann der
zoll gegeben da hab ich hab' ich hab'
ich hab' ich habe aber keine zeit
du kannst auch mal nachgucken diese
komischen links ja man muss schon wieder
zwei wirklichkeit
das stimmt natürlich
vielleicht packt jetzt erstmal kredite
40 einfluss einfluss 1 40110 2010 05 42
42 42 neckenmarkt weil ich möchte mich
gerne hier oben
das hatten wir sonst nur für sachen
pferdefleisch skandal hatten wir ja
hasse stück software amüsiert ist auch
ein ganz schnell abhaken
indem ich sage das ist mit völlig latte
weil ich es sowieso kein fleisch und ob
da jetzt war mir als verfechterin
vielleicht für mich ist dieses
vielleicht gehe ich schon ich bin schon
dreist dass man sich beschwert und
fertig ist aber dass man die schweine
und ihren einfach so fritz
das wollte ich auch sagen man ist die
ganze zeit schwein mann ist drin et
cetera aber wenn auf einmal ein pferd
ist dann beschweren sie auf einmal alle
ja natürlich kommt als moralapostel und
wirtschaftskammer dann aber beim pferd
ist dann ja wahrscheinlich medikamente
mit drin jahr geht mal zu merkels bitte
das sind nur medikamente die in sachen
biss so jedes fleisch isst macht ja
schon viel erfolg und antibiotika
deswegen esse kein fleisch
ich war auch kurz davor vegetarier zu
werden aber ich kann einfach nicht ohne
flatrate zu geil oder vor allem in svens
links ist so ein kotelett hören wenn
grillsaison es gibt einfach dieses ganze
stakes liegt auf dem grill ozean wieder
stets geile sachen osthofen oder
weißkohl auch weil ich brauche noch mehr
gremmel ein bisschen mehr
naja also mir ist eigentlich wayne
verständlich jetzt auch im endeffekt
egal wo man vielleicht nicht das muss er
wohl selber scheint
ich will doch niemand vorteil vielleicht
weil ich meine ganz toll ist vielleicht
nur ich kann vielleicht habe ich nicht
eigentlich genau wie ich das jetzt auch
sage ich verurteile keinen der
vegetarier als ich respektiere leute die
damit leben können dass sie kein fleisch
essen das für die echt cool und ich kann
sich nachvollziehen dass man es nicht
tut weil also ich kann schon nach falls
sie mal die natürlich die haltung und
die schlachtung von tieren wenn
natürlich dir jetzt einfach
eingeschläfert werden ist das natürlich
besser als wenn also die ihren sitz oder
sot oder was natürlich besser als wenn
sie da einfach sein kopf abgesägt
dann legt der körper natürlich noch ein
bisschen weiter oder irgend sowas ist
natürlich sehr sehr eklig es gibt da
auch paar videos die tasten sehr unschön
alles zeigen aber ich finde auch
nachvollziehbar dass einige vegetarier
sind aber ich kann es einfach nicht aber
ich habe trotzdem respekt vor den leuten
die es sind und deswegen aspekt an dich
sicher dass ich sehr schön aus wie du
das hier machst endest du ja trotzdem
noch mehr grip
ich habe das wirklich die jeweilig muss
einfach auf level jagt jetzt geht aber
der weg wird auch richtig lang hast du
toll für mich ja ganz viele ehrlich wie
schlosser ja richtig viele oder haben
wir aber ich brauche das auch erstmal
für den weg weil ich würd sagen dem weg
setzte weg komplett ins zeug
nein wirklich toll jetzt reihen oder ich
weise um die felder um die fehler also
ja okay stimmt ja und ja auch gar nicht
raus reicht das am feld oder wie lange
soll das noch werden das leicht erstmal
wir machen jetzt erweitern dann passt
das schon aber es gibt aber ich würde
sagen 'ich packe
hier sollen dahin reicht lasst das auch
so gerade ganz einfach weil ich denke
dass jetzt das wird genau hier leben der
fed es fällt es wird auch schöne
badetage macht genau deswegen mache ich
keinen künstlichen berg hin passt passt
passt passt das wird schwer wir machen
uns die welt so wie sie ist also die
ganze welt die werte gehen daher nicht
wiedererkennen es gibt ja youtuber die
nehmen sich die welt so ist doch gar
nicht schlecht also soll es keine
beleidigung sein ist natürlich auch cool
aber die nehmen sich die welt einfach
zurückschicken löwe gefallen sie nehmen
sich die welt wirklich einfach so wie
sie ist
ferner da gar nix aber was wirklich
machen wir nehmen uns die welt und
verändern sie komplett und das teilt das
cooler minecraft und das wort der sinn
daran dass wenn meine welt hat das wohl
alles kann verändert und verändern kann
das ist bei so so weise worte die heute
hier wieder bringen
super fackel angesagt ist schon lange
vergessen ja bei mir auch
wir feiern bis alles zerfällt was morgen
ist ist scheißegal wie es uns gefällt
oder irgendwie so dass es doch das kenn
ich ja was morgen ist scheißegal
das wird ein gekommen weil verändern die
welt sowie die uns gefällt was geht
also sah dabei ihr spiel ja gleich neun
ok muss man eben los brötchen holen
gehen
seit dem mord männern sie die haustür
rangehen klar woher die straße entlang
hier zu kaufen uns leider gibt es solche
werte bleibt neben können blunt regel
eben kurz mal ich am tresen was die
zeitung schreibt ist von großer griff
bleiben wieso das war richtig geile
musik du das war echt cool früher ohne
witz aber dafür sind zurzeit gleich so
alt ich bin jetzt auch schon nämlich ein
fachmann aber manchmal mit der heutigen
musik ist das echt anders gewesen damals
hatten dazu gemacht da war die ganze
liga ich finde das war noch richtig
richtig gute deutsche musik weil
heutzutage keine one und zwar aus aber
ich mag auch diese total gut das nehme
ich weiß nicht zum beispiel ich habe
auch jetzt freuen wir uns dieses jahr
wieder sind ja genau und er denkt wie so
what the [ __ ] also wie kann ich das
anhören
und wenn ich hab jetzt ich will nicht
sagen gegen dieses anderen ja jeder kann
es selber machen aber allein schon weil
die typen ja einfach keine ausland
vertreten ist ja alles nur show was die
machen so dass so keine ahnung dass ich
glaubwürdig oder simon kommt da nicht
auf klar
erst hat ein inhalt das hat einfach das
musik und inhalt ja ach nee ich hab
selbst einige lieder davon aber die höre
ich nur wenn ich irgendwie joggen gehe
oder sogar es einfach so lieder sind wo
der bi zu bieten
ja ich habe das erfolg einfach dass das
ist einfach nicht aber an diesem tag aus
wenn du mit ihm geredet inhalt es da
wirklich gar nichts wenn die da sagen
die gier innert darüber wie geil sie
sind ja oder dass wir den weg der arme
die haben was für den bizeps 50
us-staaten kommunen durch die kommandos
und heart of the pooh werden dann zwei
bierflaschen zur anwohner eingesetzt
oder wie wir nach einem gramm koks
stehen kommen was zu essen jetzt genau
so ist es
ich brauche eine tür eine holztür da ist
ja eine druckplatte noch schön